even if you've never seen a godzilla
movie you know
who godzilla is but as kaiju die hards
know godzilla
isn't the only monster on the roster of
touhou pictures
which launched the franchise back in
1954.
let's head to monster island and explore
some of godzilla's less known friends
and foes
a perennial background player in
touhou's kanji films for more than a
half century
manda's long serpentine body and facial
horns and barbs
suggest a connection to japanese sea
dragons of mythology and folklore
manda's screen debut came in 1963's
atragon
but the snaky beast kept largely off
screen until the film's final third
where it tangled underwater with the
flying submarine gotango
atragon is essentially manda's most
substantial film role however
a land dwelling physically restructured
version of the sea creature popped up
five years later in the 1968 kaiju rally
destroy all monsters
where it laid waste to london before
teeming with godzilla to tackle new york
city
manda was then featured in an extended
cameo in 2004's godzilla final wars
where it again battled the gotango
before finding itself on the wrong end
of a laser cannon
though always the bridesmaid on film
manda enjoyed
more substantive appearances in numerous
godzilla related video games
and comic books including idw's godzilla
rulers of earth ibero was a colossal
crustacean that guarded a south pacific
island in 1966's
godzilla versus the sea monster which
was originally issued in japan as ebora
horror of the deep though a considerable
threat to anyone
attempting to gain access to or leave
the movie's fictional letchy island
ebra's signature weapon its elongated
claws
were no match for godzilla who simply
tore off his opponent's pincers and
sent the super shrimp back to the ocean
depths
much of ebera's subsequent career at
toho seems to have been left in the
planning stage
in sea monster ebro was originally
slated to fight king kong
but american co-producers rankin bass
the stop-motion holiday animation
specialists
withdrew from the project leaving toho
to replace the ape with godzilla
ebro was also slated to appear and
destroy all monsters but
the big lobster was eventually dropped
from the script and the monster's brief
turn in 1969's all monsters attack
aka godzilla's revenge was simply
recycled footage from sea monster
ebero finally returned to the spotlight
in godzilla final wars
though its appearance was anything but
flattering with the creatures attack on
an oil refinery being thwarted by the
film's mutant soldiers
kamikoros was actually the name of three
stupendous praying mantises that menaced
both godzilla and his offspring minya in
the 1967 movie son of godzilla
the creatures impressive marionette
creations by the film special effects
director sadamasa arikawa
were first glimpsed as man-sized
mantises on a remote island before a
radioactive storm caused them to grow to
more than 50 meters in length
three king-sized kamakuras called
gymantis in the english language dub of
son of godzilla then tormented the newly
hatched minia before godzilla arrived to
fry two of them with his atomic breath
while the third was dispatched by the
island's other monstrous arthropod
inhabitant the spider kumonga
single and multiple marionette kamakuras
also appeared briefly in all monsters
attack and
1972's godzilla vs gaigan before a cgi
kamakuras turned up in godzilla final
wars
in this film the creature was seen to
possess the same camouflage abilities as
real-life fantasies not that it helped
kamakuras as the insect was quickly
sussed out by godzilla and
skewered on a transmission tower
kamikuros wasn't the only
insect bedeviling godzilla minia and the
human stars of son of godzilla
hidden inside a rocky valley was kumanga
a 150-foot spider with an appetite for
anything that crosses its path
once awakened kumonga ensnared minya and
akamakuras in its thick sticky web
which unlike most spiders jetted out
from its mouth
not its spinnerets and dispatched the
mantis with its creepy stabbing stinger
minia appeared next on the menu until
godzilla came to the rescue
the ensuing brawl was one of the film's
best displays of special effects
and undoubtedly one of its most
challenging
as the kumonga marionette required two
to three technicians to operate the
wires on each of its eight legs
eventually a combined blast of atomic
breath from father and son
brought down the spider but it or a
close relative was back in 1968 for
destroy all monsters
where it teamed with mothra to coat king
ghidorah in webbing during the films
concluding battle royale
kumanga's final screen appearance to
date was in godzilla final wars where it
displayed
a new talent a web that expanded from a
single strand to a net
this did little to stop godzilla who
simply grabbed hold of kumanga's web and
hurled him out of sight one of the
hardest working monsters in toho's
stable of kaiju
the burrowing flame ray breathing
dinosaur baragon has appeared in
numerous features
and television series over the past half
century though it's been
incognito for some of those turns
baragon made its debut in 1966 as
frankenstein vs baragon or
frankenstein conquers the world as it's
known in the states
the monster served as a replacement for
godzilla who was initially intended to
face off against toho's take on
frankenstein's monster
before production changes necessitated a
changeup baragon then returned to toho
from 1968's destroy all monsters though
its screen time was limited
why well according to some accounts it
was due to the monster's most
distinguishing feature
its long floppy ears the movie special
effects team was
concerned that this particular aspect of
the head design would make it difficult
to execute the monster's showcase
sequence
in which it tunneled under and destroyed
the arctic triumph in paris so
baragon was relegated to the background
while gorosaurus
a dinosaur from 1969's king kong escapes
got the big scene instead
in the ensuing decades baragon remained
a popular figure in countless
godzilla-related manga
novels and video games but it wouldn't
return to future work until 2001
when the creature helped to defend japan
against the rampaging godzilla in giant
monsters
all-out attack gabra is the nelson muntz
of touhou's roster of monsters
a mean-spirited bully with a distinctive
mocking laugh
and a penchant for pounding on smaller
creatures
are you alright man i
think so how about now
gabara is featured in just one film the
truly
eccentric all monsters attack aka
godzilla's revenge
and even that's not 100 real
as it turns out he was part of a
daydream about monster island concocted
by the film's protagonist
a young boy named ichiro a latchkey kid
plagued by a grade school goon he
nicknames
gabara ichiro escapes from reality by
imagining himself on monster island
where he's befriended by godzilla's
offspring minya
the pint-sized kaiju also has to contend
with its own tormentor
similarly named gabra who is a reptilian
amphibian jerk of a monster with the
ability to transmit an electric shock to
his victims
with ichiro's help and some tough love
encouragement from godzilla
minya is able to best gabra which gives
ichiro the strength to take down his own
gabra back in the real world
as godzilla grew in power to a seemingly
indestructible force of nature some of
his on-screen opponents tapped into his
incredible mutated biology in order to
create a means of defeating the creature
as a result several monsters have been
directly spawned from godzilla's
cellular structure
for example there's the colossal plant
monster biolante
in godzilla vs violante the
extraterrestrial clone space godzilla
in godzilla vs space godzilla and orga
a creature formed from dna data stolen
by alien invaders in godzilla 2000
millennium in that latter film the
overly complicated premise
involves extraterrestrial visitors known
as the millennials that see godzilla's
regenerative properties as the key to
adapting to earth's environment
and eventually overtaking the planet the
absorption of godzilla's dna allows the
aliens to combine their form
into a single towering squid creature
which then undergoes a mutation into a
hideously deformed replica of godzilla
called
orga since it possesses both godzilla's
strength and
indestructibility the new creature is
able to not only fend off the king of
the monsters but also
grow large enough to attempt to swallow
his opponent
this proves to be a fatal mistake for
orga who's blown to smithereens
when godzilla unleashes a nuclear pulse
from inside his ma
touhou's giant monster films began to
falter at the box office during the
1970s
due in part to the wealth of science
fiction and fantasy series on television
like
ultraman so moving its own fantasy and
sci-fi titles to tv was the next logical
step and in 1973 the studio introduced
the world
to zone fighter hewing to the templates
established by ultraman and
other series zone fighter's heroic
family of aliens battled an
army of terror beasts which involved one
character morphing into the show's
titular champion the colossal
zone fighter and when things got tough
he would get an occasional assist from
godzilla
the king of the monsters made his series
debut in the fourth episode and would
return for four additional episodes
zone fighter also featured two guest
villain shots by king ghidorah
though surprisingly the space dragon
didn't fight godzilla in either episode
not that zone fighter really needed his
help
if the name of this giant man beast
isn't ringing a bell that's because
it never appeared in a godzilla movie
yet trigar was featured in marvel
comics's godzilla
king of the monsters comic book which
ran from 1977 to 1979
and during the series 24 issue run
writer
doug munch and celebrated incredible
hulk artist herb trimpy created an
entirely new universe
for the radioactive monster to trample
complete with a fresh
terrifying rogues gallery some of
godzilla's comic book opponents came
from marvel's existing bullpen
godzilla battled the avengers the
fantastic four spider-man and even devil
dinosaur and
moonboy over the course of the series
others however were created specifically
for the title like yetregard a
sasquatch-styled behemoth freed from an
icy tomb in canada by atomic testing
which also boosted his height to over
100 feet
godzilla battled the monster over the
course of two issues before it was
defeated in a climactic battle
deep inside the grand canyon but that
wasn't the end of yet regards marvel run
the hairy creature would tangle with
both the avengers and the west coast
avengers before being transported to the
super secret
maximum security prison known as the
vault where he apparently
sits biding his time to this day
the 2007 video game godzilla unleashed
offered players their choice of more
than 20 of doho's monsters to take
control of for the sake of well
unleashing chaos the developers also
padded out the game's roster of classic
creatures with two new entities
designed specifically for the game
itself one of them a bipedal mutant
monster called obsidius that was created
from magma and minerals was included
after being selected from a group of
four possible kaiju by readers of ign in
a 2007 poll
the faceless brute of a creature was
given a wide array of abilities
including a lava beam which is
fitting given his original name of
magmoth in the playstation 2 version of
the game obsidius was also granted the
ability to absorb some of the life force
from his opponents
obsidius was the only new monster to
appear in both the wii
and playstation 2 versions of godzilla
unleashed which also remains his sole
showcase to date
and that's a shame because this bizarre
creature is
pretty awesome it'll probably never
happen but here's hoping we'll see him
on the big screen someday
perhaps the best thing to come from the
much maligned 1998 godzilla movie was
godzilla the series an animated sci-fi
adventure that ran for 40 episodes
between 1998 and 2001.
the show's godzilla the sole surviving
offspring of the one featured in the
tristar film was closer in both
temperament
and ability to the touhou kaiju
possessing both an aggressive attitude
and the ability to spew a fiery atomic
breath
the show also featured an impressive
array of beasts for the junior godzilla
to fight
including the loch ness monster the
aztec feathered serpent cat's cottle
and numerous mutated creatures including
giant squid rats bees worms snakes bats
jellyfish lizards of all types and
even a king-sized hummingbird that could
spit
acid the cartoon godzilla also enjoyed a
romance of sorts
with another colossal lizard a giant
komodo dragon
called comorothrax and briefly attempted
to play house with the creature and its
giant egg before their love nest was
spoiled by a giant turtle
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one